So we've been covering the sham treatments
and cures for the virus from all sorts of
different grifters.
We've looked at some well-known Christian
televangelist grifters like Jim Baker.
He's been selling a so-called silver solution.
We've looked at propagandist and conspiracy
theorist Alex Jones.
He's selling a corona virus, toothpaste that
he claims kills Corona virus.
We've also seen people like Kenneth Copeland
who are making money by receiving donations
for praying away Corona virus through the
television today.
Something very, very different today.
I have video of Okeechobee, Commissioner Bryant
Culpeper.
This is Okeechobee County in Florida.
This guy says the virus can't survive high
temperatures.
So what you can do is you take a hairdryer
and you blow hot air down your throat, aspirate
the hot air coming out of the blow dryer to
kill the virus.
Now, this is real, this guy says.
He says, I was a paramedic and this makes
sense to him.
Take a look.
This might sound kind of silly, but being
in the medical field that I was as a paramedic,
it start to make a lot of sense.
One of the things that was pointed out in
this interview with one of the doctors foremost
doctors it has studied the Corona virus says
that the nasal passages, passages and the
nasal membranes are the coolest part of the
body.
That's why the virus tends to go there until
it then becomes healthy enough to go into
the lungs.
This is sounds really goofy and it did to
me, too, but it works.
Once the temperature reaches hundred and thirty
six degrees Fahrenheit, the virus falls apart
and just disintegrates.
OK.
And I said, well, how would you get the temperature
up to one hundred and thirty two degrees?
The answer was you use a blow dryer because
it's capable of doing that.
So you hold a blow dryer in front of your
face and you inhale with your nose and it
kills all the viruses in your nose.
OK.
There is an idea right now another person
in the room immediately warned people about
disinformation that is spreading quickly.
This is not just dumb.
It's incredibly dangerous and irresponsible
to say.
And here's the key part.
OK, so Heat's talks about this so-called cure
or treatment.
Someone else in the room says you've got to
be really careful about nonsense you hear
on social media.
And he says, no, no, no, I didn't get it from
social media.
I got it from away in one America news.
That's that insane right wing propaganda channel
which Donald Trump increasingly has been promoting.
Take a look at this.
By social media, I would not even have brought
that up.
This was on a weekend and one American news
network, which is the fastest growing national
network on cable.
And it's the new Fox News, if you want to
know the truth.
And it was a doctor in a what did have his
credentials that he has been one of the foremost
doctors in studying, you know, how this is
transmitted.
And that's where that came from.
And I agree with you.
There's a lot of baloney out there on social
media.
You've got to be very careful proudly saying
I got this from, oh, a N Culpeper was ultimately
shamed into apologizing for this.
He posted to his personal Facebook page.
I am sorry for comments I made.
I was only trying to give comfort to those
in Okeechobee who have no insurance to treat
their families T.A.R.P.
I should have ignored the comments that I
perceived as hateful and the embarrassment
I caused to my fellow commissioners and our
administration administrator and her staff.
I will not offer any more suggestions unless
they are tried are proven.
I ask all of you for forgiveness for anything
offensive I've uttered during these exchanges.
Now I looked at this guy's Facebook page.
It may not shock you that this guy's Facebook
page is riddled with insane pro-Trump propaganda.
For example, a few days before his apology,
he posted.
Absolutely.
When he tried to stop Chinese from coming
into America.
The left called him racist capital.
Alan left when he tried to build a wall to
protect Americans.
The left called him racist.
Capital R on racist.
His posts looked just like Trump's tweets.
Racist is the left's favorite word to destroy
a Republican when they in fact are the true
racists.
They didn't call Obama a racist when he locked
up little kids in cages and separated them
from their parents and he deported more Mexicans.
The Trump and then once more.
I mean, it's just like the capitalization,
the grammar, the spelling.
It's all like Trump's tweets.
Just to give you a little more context about
the guy tweeting, suggesting, rather, that
you inhale hot air from a blow dryer to treat
corona virus.
He posted about an MSNBC dolt, as he called
them, saying, does this talk from a liberal?
Surprise anyone?
Let's charge Obama for the deaths occurring
in his tenure like Zaca, H1N1, Ebola and swine
flu in which he did nothing.
So that's Bryant Culpeper.
Now, serious question.
Why is it that lunatic trombonists are disproportionately
the ones spreading these insane cure ideas?
Is it political like?
In other words, they're so desperate to defend
Trump no matter what that delts tweet.
Hey, we've got a simple cure for this.
This isn't this isn't really as serious as
some people are telling you.
Is it that if you're gullible enough to vote
for Trump, you're gullible enough to fall
for some of these sham cures?
Like what is it that is making this nonsense
spread disproportionately and overwhelmingly
from Trump's supporters than from the left?
I want to hear from you.